days
11 days we are counting down for the new
year and las vegas no surprise has a
star-studded lineup to ring in 2022 i
would say who's counting but on the
bottom of our screen you'll see that we
are we are counting
christian cousins is a preview of all
the entertainment you can enjoy on and
off the strip
the countdown is on to ring in 2022 and
las vegas is ready
usher will be dancing the night away to
his popular songs as he wraps up his
coliseum residency on january 1st
a few feet away maroon 5 promises moves
like jagger at the cosmopolitan tickets
starting at 50 bucks
and the lazy song won't be a reflection
to bruno mars style as the countdown
begins he will have fans dancing to his
uptown funk at park mgm tickets are hot
and will set you back a few hundred
bucks act fast because they are selling
out fast
mizzo chainsmokers and rick ross also
saying goodbye to 2021 here in town
but not all the fun is along the strip
vanilla ice bobby brown and even the
village people are just some of the
star-studded lineup to get people moving
and grooving to an 80s and 90s dance
party at the fremont street experience
early bird tickets start at 35 dollars
if you're 21 and over kristin chenoweth
is performing at the smith center as she
performs popular hits and songs from her
new album happiness is christmas tickets
start at 45
and finally katy perry also celebrating
in town she will be launching her
resorts world residency play at the new
5 000 seat theater fans can also expect
to roar at midnight when las vegas will
showcase its own fireworks spectacular
to welcome 2022.
tone loc i'm just enjoying the 80s and
90s
yeah flock of seagulls absolutely
tickets for many of these shows are
still available they start at 35 dollars
they go up much more than that obviously
the midnight fireworks show is free they
just keep playing this so i keep dancing
we're all retro this morning i don't
hate it i love it